theo brandon
love you guys got a debate club
since theo always talks about getting
more mexicans in the nba
amen what's the best name got juancho
herman gomez
nba player the panthers
just an nfl draft shout out to brandon
in
football just drafted yator gross matos
that's a pretty good name then my
favorite rapper his name is hood rich
pablo juan oh what's the best name guys
and
let's get more mexicans in the nba he
doesn't look mexican
who is he horner i don't think he said
he was mexican yeah he's not mexican
he's down
i'm down for it but you're in nicaragua
bro yeah but
and also i'm i'm on food's gone wild
tomorrow
who's going wild the food's going wow
favorite we can just
we can just do it i'll tell you straight
up bro i'm down with [ __ ]
gross mottos though we introduced latin
names in general how about benito
santiago
dude the most mexican you can get bro is
probably hector
hector cocaine
dude i'm gonna hit you with this you
[ __ ] whities how about jeff
garcia
he's mexican mexican redhead jeff garcia
there's a lot of mexican redheads
dude that's bad fool you don't know a
real fool when you see one look at the
full starter kit look at him he's
mexican
what oh i got a good jeff garcia story
what you got doug
so i was in yon yanfrance
one of the first and only stops on the
gay train uh and uh
and he spilled wine on a new shirt that
i just got from banana republic why did
he spill wine on you what were you guys
doing
he fumbled it i don't know i was
drinking wine and he was uh playing and
he was dude where was this at where
at a nice place brendan okay i went to a
nice place with a friend
there was a rumor that jeff was gay for
a long time
but then he came out with a picture of
him and some honeys and said shut the
[ __ ] up
did they yeah he had a picture of him in
a bunch you don't have to curse every
time about it
i'm sorry it's because uh tyrell owens
told playboy that uh
jeff garcia was gay and jeff said cool
then jeff said cool hold my chicks and
there's a bunch of there's pictures of
him a bunch of chicks did anybody waste
their talent with their mouth more than
terrell owens i wonder
uh wasn't he like the best and then he
just all fell apart he's really good
i mean he kind of just got old he was he
was always famous he was still good on
dallas for
his last philly too with the super bowl
he had one leg and
balled out yeah maybe you're right he
was always a diva though he always had
problems with all quarterbacks
he beat the packers in the 1997 playoffs
he caught it and he started crying
that's my quarterback that's what he
said yeah start crying that's my
quarterback
yeah i just talked about tony romo i
think though yeah it doesn't sound like
garcia is the one that's really having
some hormonal issues
but i'm going with your boy
ucla has a one of the dopest mexican
basketball players dog
he's el futora
shout out to mexican culture shit's
tight yeah except for the violencia at
the dodgers games
that is not cool i'm gonna go on record
right now if you are mexican
and you are in the upper stands of the
dodgers games threatening
people up there people that could be
sitting there high on cocaine
trying to enjoy the game and you keep
yelling
and then when i say you're going to kill
me then you say or someone's going to
kill you
that ain't cool bruh okay where the [ __ ]
up you're high huh
yeah you make my height come down
oh you make my dog i'm not feeling good
i am not wondering your stomach huh
quit complaining though i'm light-headed
i'm getting
soft bro no i'm i'm good i'm good you
look like my
blood and blood out thank you mm-hmm
y'all are getting [ __ ] soft foams
where's that guy again ricky rodriguez
yeah a bunch of cabrons
yeah gabriel who's the ucla guy nicholas
oh he
i think i just closed it [ __ ]
how you feeling over there chin awfully
quiet very important actually feeling
wild by the way a little refreshed
like you feel a little woke you up right
this is there he is baby they say spicy
stuff makes you lose weight
maybe because you don't want to eat
anything after he should be playing for
ucla right now yeah that's last year
mexico city kid
yeah men's basketball jaime haques right
there junior
honey
damn look at him dog number four
jaime akes yuckers how do you say that
cat it's from uh i have no idea
well six six well the j is an h
and he's a straight up gee i heard a
baller dog oh yeah yeah he shoots 45
percent put
dunk on you put them chimichanga nuts in
your face dog
i respect it 26 points a game last year
no way
no nine is he still in college oh yeah
nine if you have 26 he's going sizzler
to the nba dog you average nine
minutes oh 26 minutes dang sorry
but he's good bro i'm telling you bro
yeah he seems all right
dude first of all yeah he's fresh if
he's freshman bro
damn he's a freshman mexican dude at
ucla crushing the game
yep wait he's not from mexico he's just
mexican right well he's mexican american
cat
yeah he's like my kids he's like my kids
he looks like richie valens a little bit
he does great set of hair on him
mexicans have great they got that good
they do they have great good hair like
thick curly hair yeah
when they slick it back yeah totally my
bottom bottom lip is on
fire he's coming back kids there he is
right there
don't need a spicy chip around him do
that right now
do not eat a spicy chip around him
you think chappelle's gayness was hot
you think richard valentine might have
been gay oh
no man y'all homophobic nah
y'all homophobic what's this
[Music]
is